All right. How's it going, YouTube?
Welcome, welcome, welcome. Give some
time here for people to trickle on in.
It's going to be a good stream tonight.
How is everybody doing?
How's it going, Advent Fraud Squad,
Random T Chance, Kevin Booth,
uh, Domian, welcome everyone.
So a couple months ago, Mark Finley, it
was actually
anniversary of the the great
disappointment and it was a few days
after I had started my YouTube channel.
This video was posted on Mark Finley's
uh Hope 36 Hope Lives 365 YouTube
channel. Um, for those that don't know,
uh, Mark Finley is the assistant to the
GC president, Ted Wilson. Um, and he has
a relatively large YouTube channel. Um,
but on the channel, he posted a video
titled Ellen White and True Adventist
Theology. So, of course, I had to watch
it. Um, and it's basically the current
director of the Ellen White estate,
Merlin Bert, giving a par for the course
presentation regarding the Adventist
church's theology and history. Um, with
the primary focus being to bolster the
legitimacy of Ellen White as a prophet.
So, of course, I thought this might be a
good opportunity to analyze some of
these very run-of-the-mill claims uh a
little bit deeper for people to see the
slipperiness, the halftruths embedded in
these sorts of presentations. I'm sure
Merlin's a nice guy. Um but I think he's
simply paring the same script that
they've been paring since the pioneer
days, and he's just now in the seat and
position where that's his role and
that's his duty. And so, nothing against
the guy. Um, but we're going to test a
lot of what he says in this video. But
as we examine, folks, remember this.
Actually, one thing before I get too far
down the road. I've got a bit of a
different setup going on tonight since
I'm by myself. I actually added a third
monitor into the mix. So hopefully I can
be a little bit more efficient and not
all over the place, but bear with me as
my command station is a little uh
overwhelming to say the least. Um but
remember this as we examine what he is
presenting is branded as true adventist
theology.
Remember that this is true adventist
theology. The people at the highest
echelons of this organization
know that the stuff that he is
presenting is foundational. So when you
come across SDAs that try and downplay
it or say that's not my Adventism,
that's conservative Adventism. No. know
that it is the official Adventism.
Official Adventism. So, we have a lot to
respond to um and source materials for
us to look at as we're going to break
down um what he says here into a couple
of parts. But with that said, we're
going to respond to all of it. Um
obviously, we're not going to get to all
of it tonight. We'll see how much of it
we get to. Um but with that said, let's
get into it.
We are 178 years today since the
beginning of the time of the end as it
were the beginning of Jesus final phase
in the heavenly sanctuary.
Can everyone hear the audio? I want to
test that before we get too far into
this. I have it up on my second monitor.
I know there might be a slight delay for
the crowd, but obviously don't want to
be playing this if you guys can't even
hear it. So, can somebody in the
comments just let me know? Does
everything sound good? Can you hear him?
Did you hear that small portion of the
video?
I know I hate dead air, guys, but again,
like I said, I want to make sure that uh
everyone can hear it. Okay, Kevin says,
"Yeah, it sounds good." Thank you. Let's
continue. October 22 in 1844. It was on
Tuesday. This year it's on Sabbath. And
although it's not what we're talking
about, I thought I would bring uh the
the chart, the one, we have two uh
prophetic charts at the White Estate.
This is recently acquired as a part of
the James R. Nicks collection. This
originally belonged to Jim Nicks, my
predecessor, the director of the White
Estate.
And so this is actually an original 1843
chart that was used by the Millerites. I
think you heard a bit of a story last
night. I was told by James White aka Dan
Tower that you had heard the story here.
Is that true about James White uh
preaching and having a spike thrown at
him? Remember that? And the snowballs
with debris that came in through the
windows. So you remember that story.
This is the chart that he had put up. He
had recent not this chart, not this very
one. This is an original, but it's not
the one that James White used. It could
be, but we don't know. We do have
another chart at the White Estate that
is hanging on the vault that's been
there for many years that belonged to
Ellen White and the family, but we
aren't quite sure if it's the very chart
that James White used, but this was what
he would have put up when he was telling
the story. Ellen White supported this
chart not because every detail in this
chart is correct but because it taught
the historicist view of prophecy. You
know what I mean when I say that, right?
It it is the sweep of history. Of
course, one of the dates that are are
wrong right here is this 1843, right?
Okay. So, right out of the gate,
he makes the claim Miller's chart.
Ellen White didn't agree with all of it,
folks. This is called proarication. If
you don't know what that is, look up the
term proverication.
It's where you don't give the whole
scope of something and kind of dance
around the truth. He's jumping down the
timeline. We'll get to that in a minute.
All of Miller's chart is necessary for
the Daniel 8:14 claim to be true. We've
talked about that on the channel before.
Most of you know this claim of theirs,
how central Daniel 8:14 is to their
theology.
You have to have the whole chart to
arrive at Daniel 8:14. You're not going
to hear them talk about this.
They only ever talk about Daniel 8:14.
They don't talk about Miller's other 14
proofs, which Daniel 8:14 was one of the
what's known as the 15 proofs.
So, we're not going to get deep into
that, but basically, William Miller came
up with 15 supposed proofs for Jesus
returning in, excuse me, in 1843 and
then 1844. He was obviously wrong. Um,
the guy was at least humble enough to
abandon the date setting. He didn't dig
his heels in. I try and take it easy on
him as um he wasn't really theologically
trained and was at least genuine in that
regard. Admitted he was wrong. But
nevertheless, he was wrong. And the
Miller chart was predicted or predicated
on those 15 proofs. So you have to have
the whole chart. But then the second
claim, and this is the one I want to
camp out on now,
Ellen White supported this chart because
of historicism, not because every detail
was correct.
Dr. Bert, come on.
This is what I mean by down the
timeline.
That's what it eventually ended up being
in terms of the claim was, well, the
historicism of the chart is generally
correct. That's not where she originally
was.
So, let's look at the uh le let's look
at the the the sources here on this.
Sorry, my mouse is uh freaking out here
a little bit.
All right, let's get into this.
So, this is from Ellen White's early
writings. This was at the very beginning
of all of this craziness in terms of
what's being documented. And let's
notice what she says. Remember his claim
was that Ellen White didn't necessarily
agree with every number on this chart.
It wasn't the figures.
She just agreed generally with the fact
that the historicist aspect of it was
correct. So she says, "September 23, the
Lord showed me
that he had stretched out his hand the
second time to recover the remnant of
his people,
and that efforts must be redoubled in
this gathering time." In the scattering,
Israel was smitten and torn. But now in
the gathering time, God will heal and
bind up his people. In the scattering,
efforts made to spread the truth had but
little effect, accomplished but little
or nothing. But in the gathering, when
God has set his hand to gather his
people, efforts to spread the truth will
have their designed effect. All should
be united and zealous in the work. I saw
I saw that it was wrong for any to refer
to the scattering for examples to govern
us now in the gathering. So we should be
using parallels between the scattering
and the gathering. For if God should do
no more for us now than he did then,
Israel would never be gathered. I've
seen that the 1843 chart
was directed by the hand of the Lord and
that it should not be altered.
That the figures were as the Lord or
sorry that the figures were as he wanted
them that his hand was over and hid a
mistake in some of the figures so that
none could see it until his hand was
removed.
Now, let's read the footnote that
they've added in here because this is
going to be interesting in comparison to
something Dr. Bert's going to say later
on in the presentation.
They add this applies to the chart used
during the 1843 movement and had special
reference to the calculation of the
prophetic periods as it appeared on that
chart. The next sentence explains that
there was an inaccuracy which in the
providence of God was suffered to exist.
But this did not does not uh does not
preclude the publication of a chart
subsequently which would correct the
mistake after the 1843 movement was
passed and the calculation
as then made had served its purpose.
Ellen White only agreed with the
historicist aspect. Nah,
the figures changed multiple times,
which he's going to admit, which this is
one of the primary proofs that I used to
show that Ellen White fails the biblical
test of a prophet.
The numbers weren't supposed to change
according to the Lord, but then the Lord
told her later when things didn't pan
out the right way that they actually
were supposed to change. And then they
were supposed to actually change again,
which is the iteration that he has there
on the stage.
So when things didn't work out in the
movement's favor, the blame was shifted
to God by saying he was being decepted
by putting his hand over mistake to test
his people. The blame was the buck was
passed off to God.
No, she said the figures in the chart
she agreed with because God showed her
they were exactly how he want how he
wanted them to be. And then she just
pivoted when things didn't work out.
because William Miller had said that
Jesus would come. And I brought with me
my own copy of the 1836 edition of
William Miller's lectures, evidence from
scripture and history of the second
coming of Christ about the year 1843
exhibited in a course of lectures by
William Miller. So Miller didn't set the
October 22 date ever. He came to accept
it just before the disappointment, but
he said about the year 1843. So, we call
this the 1843 chart. And there's another
little thing that you maybe hadn't heard
of, and I most people don't know about
it. There's really three editions of
this chart. It was put together by
Charles Fitch and maybe some others who
worked with him. He was staying in Hav
Haver Hill, Massachusetts. I probably
massacred that. I think it's Haval. I
think that's how they say it. You know,
Havhill. Okay, good to get that
straight. Anyway, uh if you look at this
chart, this I think is the last of the
three charts because originally there
was an image of Greece with the three
horns of the of the um generals, four
horns of the generals with a little horn
coming off of one of those horns. Well,
they kind of thought, "No, maybe that's
not right because it came from
somewhere. Did it come from one of the
horns or come from one of the winds?"
Well, we'll want not try to do the study
of that right now, but there was a
change in understanding in this chart.
And so, the picture is removed. So, you
notice there's a blank here, right?
And uh there's one with just no picture
and just like this. But then the last
one, they added another horn out here,
which is Rome, which would have then
come from one of the winds. So you have
these three additions. So this is the
last edition of the 1843 chart. Maybe
you don't care about that. Maybe it's
not that important. But the point is
this supported
the leading up bringing the world to be
aware of the soon coming of Jesus and
the great appointment that God had made
because it was a disappointment but it
was also a great appointment where Jesus
began that special work the last days in
in these last days in the most holy
place of the heavenly sanctuary.
Okay. So, he is right. Uh, William
Miller, I've heard a number of people
who get this wrong, and he's correct.
William Miller didn't set the October
22nd, 19 or yeah, 1844 date. Um, that
was one of what Doug Bachelor would call
the kooky cousins of the movement. Uh,
Samuel Snow, who thought he was also the
return of Elisha the prophet before the
second coming. Actually, let's just I've
said this a number of times. I've never
actually shown it. So, um,
here we go. I'm just going to bring this
up here because this is on the SDA
encyclopedia site. So, let's
brought up here.
Sorry, folks. I should have had this
brought up, but like I said,
later in 1845, Snow declared himself to
be Elisha the prophet, the messenger
that would appear immediately prior to
the advent of Jesus the King. This is on
the Encyclopedia of Seventh Day
Adventist.
So, this guy was a total cook, total
crackpot. He's the one that came up with
this crazy date using all sorts of wonky
Jewish math.
But again, Dr. Bert Ellen said that God
showed her the chart was not to be
altered. This was supposedly because God
wanted them to be deceived to see if
they were really loyal to the cause. But
then apparently he did want the chart
altered because they altered it multiple
times.
But then at the end he tacked in this
common thing. Christians. You're going
to hear them say this all the time, and
it shows the the 19th century mindset
that they are stuck in
a very small region of the United States
in the 19th century.
This movement is what raised the
awareness of the soon coming, the
imminent return of Jesus. He said they
made the soon coming of Jesus, they made
it aware by the Miller chart.
This is just crazy. This isn't This is
not true.
At the time of the Adventist movement,
for folks who don't know, they were in
the northeastern peninsula of the
country, which was like my spiritual
ancestors. Uh the fruits of their labors
were what this advent movement was
growing up in. The imminent return view
was not the popular view like it is
today, at least in the west.
the postmillennial esquetology
of the day was what was popular.
So because in that region that's there
was a heavy influence from Presbyterian
covenanters and Puritans coming from the
the con continental continental England
that somehow means that the whole world
thought like their region did.
So everyone believed like the
postmillennial esquetology of their
northeastern region that was heavily
influenced by Puritans. And so because
that's the case, they like raised up and
and made an awareness of the imminent
return of Christ. It's just silly. It's
silly. Adventists, stop saying this.
Don't say this. To act like you guys
like resurrected this idea from the dead
is just it's it's just silly. It's just
silly. We can find people all through
church history that had various imminent
return views. Um just the idea that
Christ could return at any moment which
is also funny because just one thing in
passing on that the Adventist church
doesn't really believe that they say
that but then this is where the
inconsistency of the system breaks down
the imminent return it he could return
at any moment so we have to be ready at
any moment yet at the same time the mark
of the beast is not a conditional
prophecy so the Sunday law has to come
first it's just there's all sorts of
those in their esquetology but just
again all of that to say that no the
advent Adventist church did not
repopularize the idea of the imminent
return of Christ. This is just something
that's part of one of these talking
points that is no, you popularize
something that wasn't popular in that
region. We didn't have internet, phones,
etc. So ideas spread by people migrating
and taking those ideas, etc.
I have a couple of other things. I'm
going to leave those for when I'm in the
middle of my presentation. Um, I was
asked by Pastor Finley to
talk with you about the biblical basis
for the gift of prophecy and the end of
time and also Ellen White's relationship
to scripture
and her work in connection with the
development of our of our doctrines and
our faith. What is her role in relation
to scripture? So, that's what we're
going to spend a little bit of time
doing together. I'm hoping to at the end
to be able to have a little time for
questions and answers. And I want to
begin with a text. It says, "So we have,
let's just pause for a moment and listen
to the words carefully because we're
going to parse this some. We can't look
at the whole parts of this text. We
don't have time today. But there's
something very important here about the
spirit of prophecy, the gift of
prophecy." Peter says, "So we have the
prophetic word made more sure to which
you do well to pay attention as to a
lamp." What does it say there? Shining
where?
In a dark place. Now try to think where
the dark place is that the lamp is
shining. As we read on, you'll see it.
It says it in the scripture here. In a
dark place until the day dawn.
And what does it say there?
The morning star arises where? In your
in your heart. So if you look at this
text, the parallel is between the dark
place and your heart. Isn't that right?
So something through the prophetic word
is shining into our hearts which are
dark. Right? It's a dark place and it
keeps shining. It keeps reaching in the
prophetic word until something happens
until light comes, right? The day dawn,
which is
the morning star. And in Revelation, we
have the key to this morning star. I
think you maybe would be familiar with
this text. It's a part of Jesus' last
words in the Bible. And it's Jesus
himself. He claims this himself. So he
is the prophet as it were and he is more
than a prophet. He is our savior. He
says,"I Jesus have sent my angel to
testify these things to the churches.
I am the root and the descendant of
David, the bright, what does it say
there? Morning star. Morning star. So
the prophetic gift shines
light into our dark h hearts
and it is really a shining of Jesus
and his spirit working to do something
in us. Isn't that right? Until the
darkness is dispelled by Jesus himself
through the spirit coming into our
hearts.
So don't miss this first most
fundamental important work of the
prophetic gift, the prophetic word.
It is to bring Jesus to our hearts.
Don't ever miss that point. Peter is
very clear. Jesus is very clear. In
fact, Peter himself is speaking with
prophetic authority. Isn't that right?
talking about prophetic authority. So he
has every
authority and word to be able to verify
and emphasize this point. And Jesus
himself does this himself.
Huh? Sorry, my mic was muted that entire
time. Sorry, audience.
I was just saying that uh so notice the
butchery of 2 Peter 2:19-21.
Um he's going to use this, as you saw,
to try and weasle in that Jesus was
speaking through the writings of Ellen
White. And by listening to her, you're
letting Jesus shine in your heart.
And I understand when you're doing these
sorts of things, you're not able to get
to, you know, every everything that you
mention in granular detail, but I think
there's a reason why they don't want to
go to the surrounding context of of this
because it's not talking about Ellen
White or the spiritual gift of prophecy.
So before getting to the verses that he
read, let's look at uh 2 Peter 1 12-15.
2 Peter 1
12-15.
So he says,
"Therefore,"
we're going to talk about what the
therefore is. Therefore,
I intend always to remind you of these
qualities.
Though you know them and are established
in the truth that you have, I think it
right as long as I am in this body to
stir you up by way of reminder since I
know that the putting off of my body
will be soon. Talk talking about death
as our Lord Jesus Christ made clear to
me. and I will make every effort so that
after my departure you may be able at
any time to recall these things.
So after exhorting the believers
to supplement their faith with virtues
like self-control, godliness, and
steadfastness. That's what he's talking
about in the the previous verses. That's
what the therefore is there for. He
exhorts them
to supplement their faith with virtues
such as self-control, godliness,
steadfastness. He says, "A life marked
by these things will persevere."
He then says he's saying these things
because he wants to stir them up by way
of reminder because he knows that he's
going to be dying soon as the Lord Jesus
told him. And he wants them to be able
to recall these words. So he lays the
foundation and then proceeds to give
them bolstering evidence to edify their
faith in Christ in the following verses,
which is where Dr. Bert read from.
So understand that's the launchpad.
So then in 16-21,
for we did not follow cleverly devised
myths when we made known to you the
power and coming of our Lord Jesus
Christ, but we were eyewitnesses of his
majesty.
For when he received honor and glory
from God the Father, and the voice was
born to him by the majestic glory, this
is my beloved son with whom I am well
pleased, we ourselves heard this very
very voice born from heaven.
For we were with him on the holy
mountain. It's talking about the
transfiguration.
And we have the prophetic word more
fully confirmed
to which you will do well to pay
attention as to a lamp shining in a dark
place until the day dawn and the morning
star rises in your hearts, knowing this
first of all, that no prophecy of
scripture comes from someone's own
interpretation. For no prophecy was ever
produced by the will of man, but men
spoke from God as they were carried
along by the Holy Spirit. He explains in
verse 16 after saying what he said
previously that the message he
proclaimed to them was not cleverly
devised myths that the apostles came up
with themselves but that the apostles
were eyewitnesses to what the Old
Testament prophets prophesied about.
They heard the voice of God from heaven
themselves.
Again, he's talking about the
transfiguration there. He's pointing
back to the prophets of old
and saying that what we're what we're
giving you today
is no different than what they were
prophesying, which is it all pointed to
Jesus. So remember this and hold fast to
this
because I'm about to die. I'm going to
be gone. But remember this message, the
message of Christ. All the Old Testament
prophets pointed to that. We didn't come
up with cleverly devised myths and
fables. That's what he's talking about.
These were ancient prophecies that
pointed to this. The same message that
we're heralding also pointed to this. So
remember that.
That's when he uses this phrase, the
prophetic word. Dr. Bert wants you to
think this has to do with the spiritual
gift of prophecy. And he's going to use
this to segue into saying Ellen White
had this and therefore Jesus was
speaking through her as a light shines
in the darkness.
Again, let's let's let's run back over
this again to make sure you got this. He
just got done mentioning the
transfiguration from Luke 9. That they
heard a voice from heaven speak over
Jesus that he's the divine son. Why is
he now mentioning this? He exhorts them
to have these Christian virtues to
bolster them in their faith as a
foundation. He's laying this to then
segue into saying what he's saying now.
Like I said, it's because those events
confirm the Old Testament prophecies.
Peter was privileged enough to have
eyewitness testimony of both the single
event and all of Jesus's other signs.
And he's saying this vindicates
everything which has been written about
the Messiah by the prophets of old.
Hence why he says the apostles were not
teaching clearly devised myths and
fables. In verse 16,
he says what they saw with their own
eyes heard with their own ears confirms
what the Old Testament prophets
predicted.
2 Peter 1:16-21 is focused on fulfilled
prophecies about Christ from the Old
Testament scriptures.
He knows that there's still prophecies
to be fulfilled, by the way. He gets to
those actually um like the return of
Christ. He gets into that in the next
two chapters. But the point being is
this is not at all about the gift of
prophecy manifest in Ellen White or
whoever any modern-day prophet.
And Dr. Bert said that this is
foundational to where they're going.
Foundational. Remember that. Sound off
to a good start here.
And of course, we have Hebrews 1 1 and
2. God who at various times and in
various ways spoke in time past to the
fathers by the prophets has in these
last days spoken to us by his what? Son.
Son. So when we look at the Bible, we do
have the prophetic revelation,
but we have
something even more precious in the
Bible. We actually have the words of
Jesus. Isn't that right? And we need to
really respect the words of Jesus. Isn't
that right? And so there's this emphasis
on the gospels, I think, and on the
importance of understanding Jesus and
what he's saying to us. But the whole
process whether it is Jesus himself
selfsp speaking when he we read his
words and read in the bible or when the
prophets are speaking it is really
Jesus shining into where again our
hearts until he is there and present. So
the whole process
of what we call special revelation, this
is what can only be not known if God
reveals it,
is a process of prophetic revelation to
connect us to our savior Jesus Christ.
No, Dr. Bert, Ellen White's writings
connect one with a false Christ that
isn't even real.
A Jesus who was
peeable and could have sinned, that
doubted his own resurrection and if his
sacrifice would even be accepted,
who functions like a Levitical high
priest in heaven, who was exalted to be
made equal with the father,
doesn't possess all of the divine
attribution,
but then he uses Hebrews 1 to set the
stage for Ellen White being a mouthpiece
for Jesus.
And he's simply reiterating here what
Ellen herself claimed,
which is interesting because Ellen
actually twisted this and inserted
herself into the verse. So let's look at
that
in testimonies for the church volume 5
page 661 for those who want to look this
up.
In ancient times, God spoke to men by
the mouth of prophets and apostles. In
these days, he speaks to them by the
testimonies of his spirit.
There never
there was never a time when God
instructed his people more earnestly
than he instructs them now concerning
his will and the course that he would
have them to pursue.
Notice that. Did you hear that? I'm let
a little bit of pause there so you can
really grasp what she just said.
There was never a time where God has
instructed people more earnestly than
until Ellen White came along. Jesus, God
in flesh, the incarnation,
walking the earth. Nope, not as earnest
as Ellen White and her testimonies.
For those that don't know, that's
oftentimes a phrase that they'll use to
encompass all of her writings that
sometimes only refers to the 10 volume
testimonies for the church set.
All the apostles? Nope.
All the patriarchs? Nope. All the
prophets of old? Nope.
God has never spoken more earnestly.
Or there's never been a time where God
has instructed people more earnestly
than until Ellen White's writings came
along.
Dr. Bert, Hebrews 1 says the opposite of
what you guys are saying.
The irony of quoting that
long ago at many times in many ways
talking about the prophets of old,
God spoke to our fathers by the
prophets.
But in these last days,
interesting fun fact that the author of
Hebrews considered themsself to be in
the last days, Adventist.
But I digress. In these last days, he
has spoken to us by his son, whom he
appointed the heir of all things,
through whom also he created the world.
God is speaking to us today in his word.
If you want to hear God, crack open the
Bible and read it out loud.
It's not speaking to you through the
testimonies, the spirit of prophecy
supposedly manifested in Ellen White.
Speaking of the spirit of prophecy,
now we're going to get into him talking
about
one of the just foundational Adventist
texts.
And so this is so important and we find
this in revelation.
U I going to spend a few minutes on this
because I think it's important for us to
understand and maybe you do understand
it but it's good to think carefully
about it. You have in the book of
revelation
um this description of the testimony of
Jesus.
Now, we've just seen really the
prophetic work is a testimony of Jesus
because it causes Jesus to come to life
in our hearts. Isn't that right? So,
here we have this uh testimony of Jesus
in Revelation. John begins. He says, "I
he bore witness to the word of God and
the testimony of Jesus Christ to all
things that he saw." And so, he's saying
he's a witness to the testimony of
Jesus. And the book ends with Jesus
himself saying, "I Jesus," we just read
this the first part, "have sent my angel
to testify to you these things to the
churches." So it is Jesus himself
testifying through the prophetic work.
We have this important text in
Revelation 12:17 that you're familiar
with. If you study Revelation, we don't
have time to study it in detail. Maybe
you've even looked at this during your
uh last few days. I'm not sure. But you
have this se sequences. You have these
sequences in Revelations. There's sets
of of of chapters that work together.
And one of those sequences is Revelation
12-14.
And so beginning and ending of that
sequence, you have this um war in heaven
that brings you right down to the end of
time that sets up this final this
sequence in Revelation. not final but
this middle sequence in the book of
revelation between 12 and 14 and it ends
with again the second coming of Jesus or
the harvest but it has right there the
third angel three angels messages and so
this is integrally connected because the
beginning and the end work together but
it's a little different than the three
angels message because it says that the
dragon was enraged with the woman went
to make war with the rest of her
offspring or the final remnant the last
part who keep the commandments of God
and have what does it say there? The
testimony of Jesus. Here's that word
again. It's the testimony of Jesus. And
of course, we look through Revelation
and we find that the testimony of Jesus
is defined in Revelation as the spirit
of what? Prophecy. So where the spirit
of prophecy is manifested or where this
prophetic gift is being active and
working, you have Jesus himself
testifying?
You have Jesus working. So when we read
the Bible
and we read the prophetic message, who's
really behind the whole thing? Jesus.
It's Jesus. You may say, "Well, I don't
see Jesus in this prophet." If you study
it and you look widely at the Bible, you
find everything is connected to Jesus.
There's nothing that isn't connected to
Jesus. And so the testimony of Jesus is
a spirit of prophecy. So wherever the
prophetic gift is manifested, it is the
spirit of prophecy that is working.
Okay? So we're going to be camped out on
this for a minute here. But did you
catch that? That's the for those that
don't know that's that's the common math
equation. your
A plus B equals C.
The claim is that the testimony of Jesus
equals the spirit of prophecy, which is
supposed to then equal Ellen White. So
again, this remember this whole thing is
being set up to like build and present
Ellen White as being a prophet, a valid
prophet.
First I want to read a quote from Ellen
White though
and then get into this anac uh
anacronistic reading of scripture. This
is from uh Lom Linda messages page 33
from 1905. So it was like 10 years
before she died. I want to notice a
couple things she says here. She says
quote the law of God and the spirit of
prophecy go hand in hand to guide and
counsel the church. And whenever the
church has recognized this by obeying
his law, the spirit of prophecy has been
sent to guide her in the way of truth.
Revelation 12:17. And the dragon was
wroth and the woman or uh yeah was wroth
with the woman and went to make war with
the remnant of her seed which keep the
commandments of God and have the
testimony of Jesus Christ. This prophecy
points out clearly that the remnant
church will acknowledge God in his law
and will have the prophetic gift.
Obedience to the law of God and the
spirit of prophecy has always
distinguished the true people of God.
And the test is usually given on present
manifestations.
So notice
God's people have always been
distinguished as those who obey the law
of God and the spirit of prophecy. They
will try and play a switcheroo here on
you oftentimes. No, no. The spirit of
prophecy, we're just talking about the
the spirit of prophecy is in the
scriptures. like you don't think you you
need to submit to the scriptures.
No, the phrase that she's using, the
context in which she's using this in is
the the spirit is manifest in her
writings. So, what's really being said
here
is that the spirit of prophecy is
referring to the spiritual gift of
prophecy and that was indeed manifest in
LG White. This means God's people are
distinguished as those who at the
present time obey the writings of Ellen
White.
But notice no mention of obedience to
the gospel.
Like Paul says in 2 Thessalonians 1:8,
he talking about God will punish those
who do not know God and do not obey the
gospel of our Lord Jesus.
This is yet again a perfect example of
why I call Adventist covenant theology
monovenantal.
In their eyes, the law and the gospel
are one and the same thing. The good
news is the law basically that you can
keep the law through the power of the
Holy Spirit. You can silence the
accusations of Satan like Jesus did in
the great controversy and be shown
worthy to the atoning benefits of his
sacrifice. They've enjoined the two
eliminating a law gospel distinction
which is why they have a cursed and
false gospel. But also notice the key
phrase here present manifestations
which refers to an active and living
prophet.
After Ellen White died in 1915, SDA
leadership was in a dilemma because they
no longer had a living prophet. So in
true SDA fashion, they redefined their
present teaching and began teaching that
Ellen White lives on through the
writings of her books. So the spirit of
prophecy now is couched in her writings.
But Merlin Bert said this quote, "Where
the spirit of prophecy is or where this
prophetic gift is being active and
working, you have Jesus himself
testifying."
This is why I can't stand when SDAs will
play these games like, "No, no, no. We
don't think that Ellen White's writings
are equal with scripture, even though we
think that uh just like she said, they
were authored by the same uh Holy Spirit
that authored the scriptures and they
are Jesus speaking." And uh Ellen White
says she never wrote a single sentence
of heresy and that the words in her
books are barricaded by a thus sayeth
the Lord.
Folks, that's what you're saying. Own
it. Own it. This is part of why
answering Adventism exists. You guys
need to own what you actually teach and
believe. And if you don't believe it,
you need to get out of dodge.
He's presenting what is branded as true
Adventist theology.
This is what is enshrined in the
official beliefs.
So if you reject Ellen White, then you
need to get out of dodge.
Come join the Christian church.
And one other thing I'll say,
folks, spiritual warfare is a
battlefield just like the physical
battlefield.
If you're not into trench warfare,
this ain't going to be the place for
you. There are other people that are
medics back at the tent, cooks in the
kitchen.
Over here, we're in the trench. There's
a big gash in my head and my jeans are
ripped and my palms are are cut.
That's the lane that this this platform
is in. There needs to be a there are
people caught up in this movement who
need a stern talking to a stern shaking.
I was one of those people and I talk
with these people regularly so I know
they are out there and they need this
sort of thing.
But no sir, that isn't what the spirit
of prophecy is referring to. Back to
what he said about the testimony of
Jesus is the spirit of prophecy.
Therefore, it's the the Holy Spirit
coming upon a person giving the prophet
a gift. The word spirit in Revelation
19:10 comes from the standard Greek word
for spirit which is numa.
There isn't a single time in the New
Testament where that is used to uh to
refer to having the gift of prophecy,
the spiritual gift. The spiritual gifts
are mentioned in 1 Corinthians 12 7-11.
And we're told that the Holy Spirit is
the source of the spiritual gifts, one
of which is the gift of prophecy. Verse
10.
But whether or not you're cessationist,
continuationist, etc.,
the phrase spirit of prophecy is not in
reference to the spiritual gift of
prophecy, but the Holy Spirit himself,
the giver of the gifts, not the human
recipient of it.
So, no, it isn't referring to a remnant
group of people who have the spiritual
gift of prophecy manifested in their
midst at the end of time.
Furthermore,
Alan White doesn't even come close to
passing the biblical test of a prophet
as we have demonstrated on this channel
multiple times. I have, CNB has, EJ
Thunder, Lorston has.
So, what is the spirit of prophecy and
the testimony of Jesus?
The same John. We're going to do a
little bit of a systematic look here.
For those that don't know, systematics
is where we look at something in total
across either the Bible or an author.
This case, we're going to do John the
Apostle.
The same John that penned the Revelation
uses the same Greek words that he does
in the Revelation regarding the
testimony in John 21:24.
John 21:24.
He says, "This is the disciple who is
bearing witness about these things and
who has written these things, and we
know that his testimony is true."
Read that again. This is the disciple
who is bearing witness about these
things
and has written these things and we know
that his testimony is true.
John says his gospel is a testimony
about Jesus. In other words, the gospel
of John is at the end of his gospel
is the testimony of Jesus.
Okay?
Same John. Let's actually bring this one
up here.
Same John, his first epistle,
1 John 5 9-11. If we receive the
testimony of men,
the testimony of God is greater.
And for this, the testimony of God that
has been born concerning his son.
Whoever believes in the son of God has
the testimony in himself.
Whoever does not believe God has made
him a liar because he has not believed
in the testimony that God has borne
concerning his son.
And this is the testimony that God gave
us eternal life.
And this life is in his son.
Whoever has the son has life. Whoever
does not have the son of God does not
have life.
The testimony of Jesus is the gospel.
Those that believe the gospel have the
testimony of Jesus in them.
It's not speaking on behalf of Jesus.
Dr. Burr is setting all this up to
support his church's prophetus and he's
simply mentioning Jesus as a supporting
element to ultimately set up support for
Ellen White. That's what this is all
about. It's all about trying to show
that Ellen White can fit the mold. So,
we have to make things work for her to
fit the mold.
And in doing so, he completely misses
the point. It's about the gospel. This
is what I couldn't stand about after I
came out of Adventism.
It's just like, but what about the
gospel? The gospel. The gospel.
Everything was about everything other
than the gospel.
It's the same thing going on here.
Just read the Bible without having to
try and bring in this 19th century
tradition. Jesus is enough. The gospel
is enough. The testimony of Jesus is
about the gospel. We're going to see
what the spirit of prophecy is, too, and
see what's being said here.
So, this is going to be a little bit of
a lengthy part, but it's going to be
necessary. I want to look at the
multiple usages of this phrasing in the
book of Revelation.
So, the first one, we're going to start
with Revelation 1 1-2, I believe. Yeah.
So, what does John say? the revelation
of Jesus Christ which God gave him to
show to his servants the things that
must soon take place.
I'll note in passing Adventist must soon
take place first century.
You think we should look at Revelation
1:1 the very first verse
that sets the stage for the the
timeline. It's not to say all of
Revelation's been fulfilled, but
he made it known by sending his angel to
his servant John, who bore witness of
the word of God
and to the testimony of Jesus Christ,
even to all that he saw, which is what
was shown to him in in vision. So John
testifies to seeing three things here.
The word of God, the testimony of Jesus
Christ, and the things that he saw in
vision.
He mentions two of these things again a
mere seven verses later
in Revelation 1:9. Revelation 1:9
where he says, "I, John, your brother
and partner in the tribulation and the
kingdom and the patient endurance that
are in Jesus was on the island of Patmas
on account of the word of God and the
testimony of Jesus."
Was John exiled the Patmos because he
possessed the spiritual gift of
prophecy?
If the testimony of Jesus equals the
spirit of prophecy, and the spirit of
prophecy is talking about the spiritual
gift of prophecy,
that's what John is saying.
No, clearly not. It was John's testimony
about Jesus, the gospel, that resulted
in him being imprisoned in Patmas. his
standing firm for and proclamation of
the gospel.
Now, Revelation 6:9.
And when he opened the fifth seal, I saw
under the altar the souls of them that
were slain for the work for the word of
God and for the testimony which they
held. Same Greek word here for
testimony.
And again, the mention of the testimony
and the word of God,
the consistent application of the SDA
interpretation of the testimony would
mean that these saints weren't martyed
for their belief in the gospel of Jesus
Christ. You know, that's not that's not
why you're going to be martyed, but for
possessing the spiritual gift of
prophecy.
No. Now, now Dr. Burke is going to
mention the objective and subjective
genative of the Greek in passing. But
the usage of testimony, Greek word where
we get the word martyr, martia
in Revelation 6:9, Revelation 12:17,
Revelation 19:10 are all in reference to
the testimony that one bears or holds
to. And this is according to the Greek
lexicon, by the way, not answering
Adventism's own personal opinion.
That's just the facts.
Look it up yourselves.
Understanding
the testimony of Jesus as being the
gospel is yet again consistent with this
saying that it is in reference to
someone who has the gift of prophecy and
speaks on behalf of Jesus is not. The
only verse that uses this language in
such a way that could be referring to
the act of prophesying is Revelation
11:7 which does not help the Adventist
claim.
Now for the Adventist favorite and the
one that was just mentioned,
Revelation 12, but instead of reading
just 17, we're going to read 10 through1
17.
It says,
"And I heard a loud voice in heaven
saying, now the salvation and the power
and the kingdom of our God and the
authority of his Christ have come. For
the accuser of our brothers has been
thrown down, who accuses them day and
night before our God. And they have
conquered him by the blood of the lamb
and by the word of their testimony.
For they loved not their lives even unto
death.
Therefore, rejoice, O heavens, and you
who dwell in them. But woe to you, O
earth and sea, for the devil has come
down to you in great wrath, because he
knows that his time is short. And when
the dragon saw that he had been thrown
down to the earth, he pursued the woman
who had given birth to the male child.
But the woman was given the two things
of the great eagle, so that the two
wings of the great eagle, excuse me, so
that she might fly from the serpent into
the wilderness, to the place where she
is to be nourished for a time and times
and half a time. The serpent poured
water like a river out of his mouth
after the woman to sweep her away with a
flood. But the earth came to help of the
woman, came to the help of the woman,
and the earth opened its mouth and
swallowed the river that the dragon had
poured from his mouth. Then the dragon
became furious with the woman and went
off to make war with the rest of her
offspring on those who keep the
commandments of God and hold to the
testimony of Jesus. And he stood on the
sand of the sea.
Before getting into all this, question
for y'all.
Did this have application to the
original audience? It was written to
before the Adventist church came around,
before any of us came around.
You saw in one one things too soon take
place. That doesn't then by proxy mean
that every bit of the book of revelation
like the hyper predtoderous claim has
already taken place
but it had application to the original
audience it was written to. This is
clearly talking about the people of God
being persecuted for their faith in
Christ and his gospel. Not a people in
the last days who will have a woman that
supposedly possesses the spiritual gift
of prophecy.
The testimony here is clearly in
reference to those who loved not their
lives unto death. Saints who were
martyed for the gospel. Nothing to do
with the manifestation of the spiritual
gift of prophecy in Ellen White or
anyone else.
Now for the other favorite Adventist
proof text which Dr. Burke mentioned,
Revelation 19:10.
Revelation 19:10
says, ' Then I fell down at his feet to
worship him, but he said to me, you must
not do that. I am a fellow I am a fellow
servant with you and your brothers who
hold to the testimony of Jesus. Worship
God.
We hold
just plug plug testimony of Jesus equals
spirit of prophecy equals you know the
gift of prophecy into that that first
part there and consider the the person
who's giving the message for the
testimony of Jesus is the spirit of
prophecy.
So John's brethren also had the
testimony of Jesus.
The testimony is here described as the
spirit of prophecy which inspires one to
testify about Jesus. This fits like a
glove with what the scriptures tell us
elsewhere about the Holy Spirit and that
the Holy Spirit is the one who testifies
about Jesus Christ. John 15:26.
But when the helper speaking about the
Holy Spirit comes whom I will send to
you from the father, the spirit of truth
who proceeds from the father, he will
bear witness about me.
This also fits with the grammar that the
spirit of prophecy again isn't the gift
of prophecy manifest in someone but is
in reference to the Holy Spirit himself.
And the testimony being the gospel of
Jesus Christ.
The final mention I want to look at
Revelation 20:4.
Oh, there it is.
says, "Then I saw thrones and seated on
them were those to whom the authority to
judge was committed. Also, I saw the
souls of those who had been beheaded for
the testimony of Jesus and for the word
of God."
And those who had not worshiped the
beast or its image and had not received
its mark on their foreheads or in their
hands, they came to life and reigned
with Christ for a thousand years.
Again, what were these martyrs martyed
for?
having the spiritual gift of prophecy
and Jesus speaking through them as
prophets.
No, for the gospel. For the gospel.
Again, John mentions the pairing of the
word of God and the testimony of Jesus.
This parallels perfectly with what we
just saw back in Revelation 6:9 and his
first epistle.
So throughout the New Testament, we find
that the testimony of Jesus
refers to the believer's personal
witness about Jesus Christ and his
gospel. It is not exclusively about
prophetic utterances received from
Jesus,
but the believer's personal testimony
about Jesus. Are there instances where
people uttered prophetically and the
spirit was behind it? Absolutely. No
question about that. But it isn't
exclusive to that act.
The spirit of prophecy is about the
person of the Holy Spirit, not the act
of prophesying and speaking on God's
behalf.
They are twisting something about the
Holy Spirit himself in the name of
propping up Ellen White. Shameful.
All believers have the spirit of
prophecy and the testimony of Jesus.
The testimony of Jesus is found in the
writings of the New and Old Testaments.
whose writers personally knew Christ and
bore witness to him.
Furthermore, Dr. Bert earlier mentioned
the light shining in our hearts. Well,
John tells us that the testimony of
Jesus is found in the heart of those who
accept and believe in Jesus as the son
of God. As we read in first John
earlier,
he that believes on the son of God has
the witness in himself.
1 John 5:10.
The testimony of Jesus is not a phrase
that can be uniquely used to identify
the SDA church as the remnant church of
Bible prophecy.
As we just saw in Revelation, clearly it
teaches that John had the testimony of
Jesus. Revelation 1:9. The martyrs had
it. Revelation 6:9. John's brethren had
it. Revelation 19:10. This is long
before Ellen White.
Long before any of these other supposed
prophets.
It had application long before the SDA
church was born in the 1800s.
So again, I want to reiterate this. This
is key to remember. The spirit of
prophecy is possessed by any believer
who has the indwelling of the Holy
Spirit,
not just those who the spirit gives
prophetic utterances to.
That's how they're trying to position
this. Because if you were to ask them,
"Well, does every believer have the
spirit of prophecy?" Well, they would of
course say no because they're equating
it to a person who Jesus is speaking
through and every believer Jesus isn't
speaking through every believer.
That's the issue. You're narrowly
applying this to supposedly say the
identifying mark of the remnant church
and it was manifested and white. So
therefore, we're the remnant church of
Bible prophecy. It's the snake eating
its tail.
Christians can consistently apply these
phrases across the board as being about
the gospel and Jesus and the Holy Spirit
himself. The Adventist Church cannot.
And it's also rather ironic considering
they claim to let scripture define
itself. Ted Wilson at the the last
annual convention or annual summit or
whatever it's called and the the GC
session said that the only approved
hermeneutic in the Seventh Day Adventist
Church is the historical grammatical
method, HGM.
Folks, if you apply HGM to this, you
would never arrive at the conclusion
they're arriving at. For those that
don't know, HGM the is simply seeking to
understand the text from the standpoint
of the original audience it was written
to.
Adventists are chopping up Revelation to
make it be talking about a group of
fringe people in the northeastern
peninsula of the United States in the
19th century.
Yeah, I'm sure that's what John was
being given vision of.
So, no, Dr. Bert, you and your
organization are mistaken, sir. You're
mistaken. Either that or you're
knowingly dishonest. You seem like a
nice guy. I don't think you're you're
like being a deceiver. You're just
giving this sort of cookie cutter
presentation that you're all your
pioneers gave and whatnot. But now, he's
going to mention all these passages in
passing and even admit that some of
these usages of the phrase testimony of
Jesus refer to people's witness of Jesus
himself.
And he's correct like I mentioned
regarding the lexican
and not just the I just know that the
agrees with this
but he's going to say revelation 12:17
is different and this is not true. The
only usage of this phrase again that
could potentially be in reference to
prophetic utterances speaking on behalf
of God is Revelation 11:7. And again
that does not help their case.
So let's continue here. This this next
clip is a little bit longer. It's about
4 minutes. So, I don't want to spend too
long on this, but I just want to tick
through a few points to be aware of on
this issue of this this testimony of
Jesus. And I pause when I say it each
time. You know, those are powerful
words.
Testimony of whom?
I want to hear a testimony of Jesus.
Don't you? That's important. The phrase
is used in five verses.
uh you have them listed there.
Revelation 1 2 and 9 12:17 1910 and 20:4
two are used maybe there's too much
Greek here but the objective genative in
the Greek which has to do the witness of
believers towards Jesus so you have a
testimony uh to Jesus or of Jesus but in
many ways those are also a testimony of
Jesus because when the martyrs died they
were testifying for Jesus weren't they
but still it's this is the focus three
though have this subjective genative
which is they have or they bear witness.
In other words, they share the testimony
of Jesus. What Jesus has said, they
share. They communicate.
In Revelation 19:10, we have already
seen that it identifies uh Jesus
identifies prophets as those who have
the testimony of the spirit of prophecy.
Um, part of what I have here comes from
the book gift of prophecy in scripture
in history that the white estate has
published and we had a symposium in 2015
and one of the chapters was by Ronos
Stfanovich and he talked about this
issue of the testimony of Jesus and he
observes that many Jewish tarams in
John's day and be and even before the
time of Jesus and John use this term uh
spirit of prophecy to refer to the
prophetic ministry. So there is this
sense of understanding that when the
word spirit of prophecy is used,
testimony of Jesus is not used in the
tarans. But when spirit of prophecy is
used, it's a a prophetic activity. And
of course, we have God's final people at
the end of time, the final remnant
having the testimony of Jesus.
The testimony of Jesus therefore would
refer to where whatever way Jesus has
testified including modern prophetic
communications. In fact, the where it's
placed in the whole process of
revelation um 12
strongly urges us to think that the
final church, the final remnant is
keeping the commandments of God and they
have living active testimony of Jesus or
the spirit of prophecy that is active
there. And so whether it's the Bible or
whether it's a modern prophetic
manifestation,
it is a a mark a hallmark of God's
people at the end of time. So the spirit
of prophecy is not an exclusive term to
refer only to Ellen White's ministry. It
is a general term that applies to those
who have the prophetic gift. So John of
course the
so that Ellen White quote we read
earlier
living and active prophet that's now
being redefined as alive and active in
the writings of a dead woman from the
19th century.
They don't have a living and active
prophet. The Mormons have you beat sir.
They claim to have living prophets.
But he mentioned the Jewish tarams. The
Targam,
for those that don't know, the Targums
are an Aramaic interpretation of the
Hebrew Jewish scriptures provided by
rabbis.
Basically, their ex Jesus of Old
Testament passages.
He said they used this term to refer to
the prophetic ministry.
So there is this sense that when the
spirit of prophecy is used, it is a
prophetic activity. He said it's not
exclusively to Ellen White, which I
would ask them, where's the other
prophets then? Oh, and they'll typically
say, 'Well, when the latter reign
happens, all sorts of people will be.
But until then, only Ellen White.
Silence until the 1800s and then Ellen
White and then she dies and now it's
just couched in the writings of Ellen
White.
But notice he said it's not exclusive to
Ellen White. It's anyone that has the
prophetic ministry. No, it's not, sir.
It is not exclusive to people that have
the gift of prophecy.
What about the tarams? No, sir. The
tarams do not refer to the spirit of
prophecy being the New Testament gift of
prophecy like the SDA church claims was
manifested in Ellen White, but rather
again the person behind the gifting
which is the Holy Spirit himself.
They very much do mention those in the
Old Testament period who gave prophetic
utterances, but it isn't to the
exclusion of everyone else. I'm going to
keep saying this. This is the key
because they're making it this
exclusionary thing because then it's the
identifying mark for the remnant church.
The spirit of prophecy is not exclusive
to those who give prophetic utterances
from God. Whether you believe in the
charismatic gifts, the sign gifts still
being active today or not, that's a
different discussion. The point is the
spirit of prophecy is possessed by all
believers.
They say this as though the spirit of
prophecy only belongs to those who the
Holy Spirit comes upon to give prophetic
utterances. It's just not true. All
people who have the spirit, the Holy
Spirit, have the spirit of prophecy.
He's housed in the church, the body of
Christ, the temple of the living God,
indwelling God's people.
Because the testimony of Jesus is the
gospel of Jesus Christ. And all who
believe in the gospel have the
indwelling of the Holy Spirit.
That's why that's what's being said.
It's the gospel. The gospel bears
witness of Jesus. Yes, God has spoke
through prophets of old, etc. that
pointed to Jesus. Absolutely. But all
believers have the spirit of prophecy
and the testimony of Jesus.
But even so,
Ellen White does not even come close to
passing the test of this. So even if we
grant that, even if you grant, yeah,
there's still prophets for today, she
doesn't even come close to passing the
test. Like not even close.
Now, evidence for my claim regarding the
targam and the use of spirit of
prophecy. I have a paper here from
Archie Hui.
Archie Hui is a
um sorry, he's a leader in the the
Christian church in China. He's a
professor of New Testament at China
Evangelical Seminary. Uh and his
specialty is in pneumatology. again that
phrase numa the spirit the study of the
holy spirit the doctrine of the holy
spirit
in the introduction of a paper he wrote
titled the spirit of prophecy and
Pauline pneumatlogy
he writes
that the spirit of God is known as the
spirit of prophecy in Judaism is Not
hard to demonstrate.
The spirit of prophecy in the Targums is
referring to the Holy Spirit himself.
Now, yes, of course, there are times
where the Holy Spirit came upon a person
and they spoke prophetically, but that's
not to the exclusion of the Holy Spirit
being present with all modern-day
believers today who experience the
indwelling of the Holy Spirit.
most obvious pl or the most obvious
place to look is in the Aramaic Targums
in Tarum in Tarum Ankalloy. Joseph is
said to have the spirit of prophecy in
him after he interpreted Pharaoh's
dream. So Tarum uncle comments on that's
exesus of Genesis 41:38. Similarly,
Joshua is said to have the spirit of
prophecy in him. Numbers 27:18. The
spirit of prophecy is said to rest upon
the 70 elders of Israel and they
prophesied as a result. See,
of course, when people prophesy and the
spirit comes upon them, of course, the
but the focus on the term spirit of
prophecy is the person, the person of
the Holy Spirit. And then the same thing
happened to Balum, the false prophet.
That's Taraloy in number 24 or Numbers
24:2.
The spirit of prophecy is the Holy
Spirit himself.
is not simply in reference to an
individual who's speaking on behalf of
God, but rather the Holy Spirit himself
either in or on a person.
Again, it does not mean that people who
spoke prophetically in the past, that
term is not being used because of course
the Holy Spirit is the one that's doing
that. But again, it's not to the
exclusion of everyone who doesn't speak
on behalf of God or in Ellen White's
case, plagiarize and then try and pass
it off as being from God himself, which
is a violation of the third commandment,
by the way.
But we can look at another source, an
article from the Journal of uh Biblical
and Theological Studies from John
Roning. I think he's retired. Yeah.
Former professor of biblical studies and
the director of uh the doctoral program
at Faith Theological Seminary. He wrote
a book titled the Jewish Targams and
John's Logos Theology.
Extremely qualified to speak on Yanian
language and the Targam,
but he says, "Whoops, I hit stop sharing
instead of uh switch sharing." One
second.
All right.
He says,
under heading target ways of translating
references to the spirit of God.
In a number of passages,
the Tarums add a reference to God's
spirit where there is no such reference
in so MT for those that don't know is
the Maseretic text. We're talking about
Old Testament scriptures here. Um or the
Maseretic tradition
and sometimes references to the spirit
of God are interpreted as a spirit of
prophecy or wisdom.
And there are a few cases where the
divine word is employed from the
Maseretic traditions references to the
spirit of God.
So he affirms or he reaffirms rather the
phrase spirit of prophecy is a phrase in
reference to the holy spirit not only in
cases where someone gives a prophetic
utterance or has the spiritual gift of
prophecy but in reference to the spirit
himself which is what revelation 12:17
is actually in reference to like we
looked at.
He continues in here,
the expressions, a spirit of prophecy
and a spirit of holiness sent from God
might be taken in an impersonal sense,
but there are a number of cases where
the Tarums add the Holy Spirit where
there is no reference to the spirit of
God in the Maseretic tradition. Tarum
Ankalloy in Genesis 45:27. So this is
what Archie Hw mentioned says that the
Holy Spirit rested on Jacob when he
found out from his sons that Joseph was
alive and saw the wagon sent by him. On
the same p uh of the same passage Tarum
suita Jonathan says that the spirit of
prophecy which had left Jacob when
Joseph was sold returned and rested on
Jacob. In Targum Suda Jonathan Genesis
27:5, Rebecca heard by the Holy Spirit
as Isaac gave instructions to Esau. And
again in verse 42, Esau's words were
shown to her by the Holy Spirit. Jacob
is also said to be uh the subject of
revelation or to speak by the Holy
Spirit in Tarum Suda Jonathan Genesis
30:25, 31-21, 37, 33, 43:14.
In Tarum Neaphiti, Genesis 42:1 says
that Jacob saw by the Holy Spirit and
there w that there was grain in Egypt.
In Tarum Suda Jonathan, Exodus 33:16,
Moses in speaking with God says the uh
that Israel is distinguished from the
nations by the spirit of prophecy being
withheld from them and by your speaking
by the Holy Spirit to me and to your
people.
Also, we'll note below in paragraph 8 or
section 8, the divine word is to be uh
revealed to increase the Holy Spirit who
is with you. It's Moses to put upon him
the 70 talking about the 70 elders I
believe in Tarum Neaphit numbers 11:17
an experience is to be repeated with the
giving of the holy spirit to the
disciples by Jesus John 20 and22
the opposite is the case when god's
people experience judgment the word of
the lord will hide the spirit from you
when the plagues come upon you and upon
your children and I have spoken in my
word to withhold from them my holy
spirit
So what's the point of all of this? The
point in showing that is saying that no,
the Jewish Tarum do not support the idea
that interpreting Revelation 12:17 as
being about Jesus speaking through a
woman in the 18 and 1900s, which is what
Dr. Bert is trying to support through
making reference to the Tarums. It's
about the spirit of God who all born
again believers possess and the
testimony of Jesus which is the gospel
of Jesus Christ that all born again
believers believe uphold and affirm. And
it's the Holy Spirit that bears
testimony and witness to Jesus. That's
what's going on.
Quoting the tarams to somehow bolster
Ellen White doesn't work. That doesn't
then support your guys's twisting of
Revelation 12:17 to be talking about a
hallmark identifying sign of a last day
movement who is God's true church that
is restoring essentially what fell away
from apostolic times.
The Adventist church loves doing this.
They love appealing to outside sources
like this when they think it helps their
case to build credibility.
Do some of the Targums like Tarum,
Neaphiti, Suda, Jonathan, as we saw
Numbers 11:25, for example, talk of the
spirit of prophecy coming upon people
and they begin to prophesy? You betcha.
No doubt about it.
The issue is the claim that the spirit
of prophecy is reserved for people who
prophesy.
It isn't.
And this is supposed to be how the
Adventist church is identified by being
God's end time last day church.
which was again predicated off of a
butchering of second Peter 1.
Dr. Burke, it is not a term reserved for
those who have the gift of prophetic
utterances. Those that genuinely do so
obviously do have the Holy Spirit, but
not only them. This does not help your
interpretation of Revelation 12 and
19:10.
Also, would he have the spirit of
prophecy?
Of course, he would. The whole Bible is
a spirit of prophecy. But where you have
true prophetic
special revelation, there you have the
working of the spirit of prophecy. There
you have the testimony of Jesus being
manifested. So a few texts, maybe you're
familiar with these, but just to make it
clear in our minds, Joel makes it clear
that at the end of time, there would be
a manifestation of uh the gift of
prophecy. at the end of time. Of course,
Peter applies it to his time as well,
but it certainly would transcend down to
the final time because these are both
crucial periods. It shall come to pass
afterward that I shall pour out my
spirit on all flesh. Your sons and your
daughters shall prophesy. Your old men
shall dream dreams. Your young men shall
see visions. The sun and the moon shall
be turned into darkness, the moon into
blood before the coming of the great and
awesome day of the Lord. We also find in
uh Paul's lists of spiritual gifts we
have the three places here. Each one
mention the prophetic gift in those
lists which would suggest that this is
not something that is just for the New
Testament church. It is something that
is to continue in the Christian church.
And both Jesus and John warned against
false prophets. And they wouldn't say
they were false if they weren't true.
Isn't that right? So we don't have time
to go into a lot of detail but I thought
just a few texts to think about this but
it's very
uh appropriate and right for God at a
crucial time in earth's history the end
of time just before Jesus comes that he
would manifest in a special way the
spirit of prophecy which is his own
testimony in connection with this day we
think of it especially as we're here at
the end of time.
Okay, so he used one of their favorite
The pioneers loved this.
He used one of their favorite lines
about obviously the gift of prophecy is
still active and well because the Bible
wouldn't have warned against false
prophets if there weren't real ones.
James White, Uriah Smith, they all love
this argument.
Without this getting into a gazillion
parts, we'll have a video where we deal
specifically with with that. But let's
for the sake of of tonight just grant
that that's true. Okay.
For the eenth time, Ellen White does not
even come close to passing the biblical
test.
This claim only kicks the problem one
one step further down the road. Folks,
instead of arguing whether or not the
gifts of pro the gift of prophecy is
still active for today outside of the
scriptures,
just grant Adventists that and cut
straight to testing Ellen White. They
love to try and try and and discuss like
vague generalities,
but the whole reason they're in support
of the gift of prophecy is because they
need Ellen White for the House of Cards
to stand.
She's the chief card stone, if you will,
the ace of spades.
So, just grant him the gift of prophecy
and go straight to using the Bible
standard for how it how to test a
prophet. She gets a whopping F,
maybe a D minus for feeling generous.
Ellen White is not vindicated, folks, by
simply demonstrating that the gift of
prophecy is still active today.
That only proves that general point
that okay, yeah, prophets are for
active, you know, today.
But now let's examine yours
and the Mormons and any other person
that wants to claim they're a prophet.
Then he points to the Miller chart in
1844 to say that the spirit of prophecy
manifested in all of that through Ellen
White.
Folks, if that was the work of the Holy
Spirit, the Holy Spirit is
schizophrenic, confused, and a liar.
And yeah, I'm completely content in
saying that because I know him and he
isn't. Which is why I know 1844 was a
fraud.
Remember Ellen said the Lord showed her
not a figure of the chart was to change.
It was exactly how he wanted it. Then it
became, well, God had his hand over a
figure in the chart to test us. And then
the chart changed multiple times.
So they passed the buck off to God.
No, the spirit of God was not behind
that mess. And it's shameful to
attribute such a thing to him,
making God a deceiver
and passing the buck off instead of the
obvious elephant in the room.
Folks, if if the God that was active in
all of this fanaticism,
he must be the worst communicator in the
world or he's a deceiver.
We discussed this specific failure on
her part. We're going to get into other
ones in the coming months.
It's just
ridiculous to equate God with that mess.
Crazy.
Of course, we think of Ellen White who
was one of the three principal founders
of the 7th Day Adventist Church, but
also someone who received visions and
dreams for a period of over 70 years in
her life. Uh, this is a colorized
picture. We don't have any actual color
pictures of Ellen White, but at least
from what we can tell, the color of this
dress is probably either this color or
more of a green equivalent of this.
We're not sure cuz it's black and white,
but uh when you think of Ellen White,
don't always think of her only as
wearing black. Okay, can you do that? Uh
it makes you kind of a scared of her
sometimes, but she didn't just wear
black. Anyway, so she had visions and
dreams beginning in December of 1844 and
continuing throughout her lifetime for
about 40 years. She had many times
visions in settings whether in churches
or in homes or other places where God
spoke to her and she had supernatural
manifestations in her experience. I
brought with me uh this Bible.
This belongs to me. This is the same
edition though as the Bible that Ellen
White held in vision when she was newly
soon after when she uh had her first
vision probably around March of 1845.
This does not have the Apocrypha in it,
but it's the same 1822
um Bible that we have in the White
Estate. If you come there, you can see
the original Bible that belonged to the
Harmon family there in the vault, but
you can't hold that one. But she
envisioned as a young girl, still 17,
but uh this is um a little lighter
because it doesn't have the apocrypha.
It's about 17, a little over 17 pounds.
The one with the apocrypha, which was
what was in their in at their home, is
about a pound heavier, a little more.
So, it was heavier. But she envisioned
not knowing what she was doing. This was
not valitional. When she would have
visions and dreams, it was not at her
choosing, not at her deciding. It was
God who decided. And so he took her led
her or used her to go over to the family
altar, pick up the family Bible, and
hold it on extended arm. I'm
left-handed, so I'm going to hold it on
my left arm because it's too hard. But
she held it extended like this
for about 20 or 30 minutes. Now, she was
a petite,
frail
at that time in poor health. And so,
that was remarkable because under normal
circumstances, she could hardly even
lift the Bible. But that is not the most
important point that I think God was
trying to say. Yes, he was trying to
demonstrate that what was happening to
her was more than her. That it was God
working. It was him working. It was
supernatural. Now, supernatural could be
from Satan as well. And you have to test
it. Isn't that right? We're not going to
take time today today to go through the
tests of a prophet. But one of them is a
crucial one is they must speak in
harmony with what? The word of God, the
Bible, to the law and to the testimony.
Isaiah tells us if they speak not
according to this word, it's because
there's how much light in them? No light
in them. And so God caused her to pick
that Bible up and hold it in vision. And
I like to emphasize more not the point
that it's it's supernatural. That's
remarkable.
But what's more remarkable is at the
very beginning
he is trying to emphasize
that his work through Ellen White is to
take us to scripture. Don't miss that
point. We're going to very carefully
study that.
Oh my goodness, man.
I wonder why he doesn't want to talk
about and I get again you're you're
giving a presentation but it's just the
the irony.
I think I know why he doesn't want to
talk about the test of a prophet.
Associating her holding a big Bible out
as a little frail girl uh isn't one of
the signs of being from God which he
recognizes obviously.
Adventists have been saying this for a
long time. I I consider this story to at
this point to basically be like
Adventist folklore.
If you grew up in that world, we always
heard this story of God supposedly
working through Ellen White by means and
giving her supernatural strength to hold
out this enormous Bible for an extended
period of time.
He rightfully recognized obviously that
this really doesn't mean jack because
superhuman strength can be from the
devil like the Garazine demoniac of Mark
5. So why even mention this? So what? So
what?
Who cares that she held out this?
They're just throwing this in there
because this is like part of the story.
It's like, well, I know that this could
actually be from the devil. We don't
want to talk about the test of a prophet
either. this little frail woman, she
held out this big Bible like this. All
right, moving along. It's just to
bolster this idea to you folks that
like, oh, wow, yeah, that's crazy. Oh,
man.
He said this is supposed to confirm that
God was showing us the Bible is supreme.
The whole narrative is laden with the
presupposition that no one was reading
the Bible until the Adventist came
along. that God needed Ellen White to
point the world back to the Bible
because no one was reading it.
It's just silly, man. It's just silly.
It's just standard fair recycle repeat
style Adventist presentation
that like I said, if you've been an
Adventist for like more than 5 seconds,
you've heard at university, at Adventist
summer camp, in grade school, who cares
that Ellen White supposedly held a big
Bible out extended
We're supposed to overlook that a that
the woman failed the biblical test of a
prophet because God used her to hold a
big Bible as a frail young girl for an
extended period of time
and God did and that's what God was
using to point people back to the Bible
that people were
this idea that like there weren't
theologians around like no one was study
what's really being said by that is no
one had the insight like we knew
everyone else was kept in the dark. This
is their restorationism that they want
to so avoid coming through. It's just
not sound reasoning, guys. This is not
sound reasoning. Why even bring up this
stupid story if you know it's like,
well, it doesn't really prove anything.
Okay, continue. Gosh,
I have spent for a number of years time
looking at this issue of how we should
understand and read Ellen White. And let
me just tell you something that I am
totally settled on. And if we had time,
I could do 10 sessions on this too. And
that is for Ellen White there are two
foundational
motivating influences and orientations
that she she has. Now you can add a
third. I'll mention that one because we
don't want to overlook it.
The third flows out of the first two and
that is she is focused and passionate
and constantly focused and passionate
about the love of God revealed in Jesus
and his death on the cross. And if you
don't understand that about Ellen White,
you will not understand Ellen White. And
the second is she is oriented entirely
toward the Bible, toward scripture. If
you've done any reading her writings,
you know this is true. Isn't that right?
Yes. And of course, those two things
made her passionate about having souls
come to Jesus. Isn't that right? So, we
can't not mention that one. So she's
that's a fundamental passion, but it
flows
completely oriented to the cross of
Christ and the scriptures. Folks, you're
going to hear this all the time. Ellen
White always pointed us back to the
Bible. She's the lesser light that
points to the greater light, which is a
terrible analogy and makes absolutely no
sense. It's like shining a flashlight
into the sun.
Makes no sense at all.
But completely oriented toward the cross
of Christ in the scriptures. They're
always going to hone in. Oh, she said
this so beautifully over here. Yeah,
except for those times where like in her
paper of the second vision which she
said she was shown the door of mercy was
shut for everyone but the little flock.
The whole world lost except for like
Steve Daly has studied it out 150 people
supposedly.
Or when she claimed multiple times to be
shown by God that various aspects of
individuals private lives and hung it
over their head.
Or when she said, "If you go against her
writings, you're going you aren't merely
going against her opinion, but you're
actually insulting and going against the
spirit of God." Or when she said things
like, "If you go against her writings,
it's to have the same fate as Kora,
Dayan, and Abby who went against God."
Or when she said uh in the spirit of
prophecy
or said the spirit of prophecy, her
writings and the Bible both have the
same author, the Holy Spirit. Or when
she said, "If you go against her
writings, the spirit of God will be
withdrawn from you." Or when she
blasphemously said that while on the
cross, Satan was able to twist the mind
of God
to doubt his own resurrection and become
unsure if his sacrifice would even be
accepted by the father or if he'd be
eternally separated from him, causing
eternal separation between a person of
the triune God.
You mean those statements, Dr.
about cross about the cross and Christ
that only the father could could
resurrect the son but then contradicted
herself and said that Jesus did too
because she wasn't an integrative
thinker and would just pull ideas from
all over the place not knowing if it
contradicted things she's already
previously said.
I get so sick of hearing the same tired
trope that Ellen White only ever exalted
Jesus and pointed people to the Bible.
This is such a load of hogwash.
The Adventist Church is saddled with all
of Ellen's writings, not just the
flowery, fluffy, pie in the sky,
loveydvey quotes where it sounds like
she's talking about some longlost lover.
No, you're stuck with all of them. She
put herself in that category, by the
way. She claimed these things of
herself. She's the one that said it's
either all of God or all of Satan.
She's the one that says she never wrote
a single sentence of heresy. She's the
one that said the words in her books are
barricaded by a thus sayeth the Lord.
She's the one that says if you go
against her, you're not just going
against her opinion. You're going
against God and the spirit of God will
be withdrawn from you.
That's her own standard. Adventist,
that's not us just picking on her. It's
all or nothing.
You're stuck with the ones about the
true Christian church being apostate,
following after Satan with its members
praying members prayers being an
abomination to God and actually going to
Satan. that our churches are filled with
evil angels masquerading as Christians
as well as have bled over now into the
Adventist church and there's the omega
spirit
that Jesus is only interceding on behalf
of Adventists
that our prayers again are an
abomination to God.
It's important to understand that this
is standard MMO for Adventism. It's
always Ellen White was this meek and
lowly servant of God and everyone who
critiques her is the big bad wolf coming
to snatch the pigs. This is laughable
when you put the work ac when you look
at the work across the board.
Her claims to parents prayers not going
higher than the ceiling because meat,
butter, and eggs are on their tables.
Meanwhile, Willie White, her son, is
writing letters that Ellen loved beef
steaks and oysters and venison and
salmon and beef tea and all sorts of
other stuff that she was forbidding for
others. rules for thee but not for me.
Saying their souls were in danger,
folks, but was herself eating
all of those things until the late
stages of her life,
putting other people in undue bondage
from a place of authority, knowing that
these people believe that you're
speaking on behalf of God
and you're not even yielding your your
own advice.
Shameful. Shameful. And shame on the SDA
church for these
just silly presentations where it's just
going off all the different talking
points.
Trying to paint and proaricate.
It's leaving out finer details about
things. No, you're strapped with all of
this stuff, not just the fluffy quotes.
She falsely spoke on behalf of God,
bearing his name falsely, violating the
third commandment. Time and time again,
she exalted and taught a false Jesus,
which is idolatry and an idol, violating
both the first and second commandments,
worshiping a false god in a false way.
Oh, but we're supposed to believe she
just exalted Jesus as a meek and lowly
servant. Please,
give me a break.
Give me a break.
So disclaimer about these next couple
parts. I would skip over them or mask
over it if I could because the uh are
second commandment violations uh in
their false depictions of a member of
the godhead. But I want to respond to
what he says. So for those that have
that same conviction,
shield your eyes
out of those other two, those are the
foundations that anchor it. And so when
we think about her and Jesus, uh, her
first three major visions
all have Jesus as the center of the
vision. I don't know if you've thought
about that. This is a painting that's
down in the white estate along a wall.
It's beautiful. It represents her first
vision, Christ of the narrow way. And on
this path, God's people are following
Jesus to the new Jerusalem. Don't miss
that point. Who are they following?
And he is leading them along the path.
and they get discouraged and he raises
his arm and light wafts over them. And
the only time you're in danger of
falling off the path is if you take your
eyes off of Jesus and you look to
something else. Isn't that right? And
when that happens, and then she says,
"Also, they rejected the light behind
them, which was the midnight cry." This
is the prophetic foundation.
The other thing you can't disconnect
from Ellen White is a understanding of
the prophetic movement of God in history
because she's handinand with the Bible
on that. And so God showed her in her
first vision about this. But the point
is they're following Jesus on the path
to the new Jerusalem. And so this first
broadside of Ellen White has these three
visions and one other. And I mentioned
the first one already, the Christ of the
narrow way or the midnight cry vision is
Jesus who's leading them on the path.
Her second major vision we sometimes
call the bridegroom vision where she
sees Jesus leading his people or he goes
into the most holy place and they have
their eyes on him where he is a great
high priest. And then you have this
beautiful third vision of Ellen White or
Ellen Harmon at the time still being
taken in vision to the new earth. Oh, I
wish we had time today just to talk for
a while about that vision. Have you read
that in early writings? Go back, read it
again. Talk about powerful. Now, that's
a vision I wish I could have. Some of
them I'm not so sure cuz it's hard
challenge. Although,
Dr. Bert, I have read Ellen White um
lots of her.
What an interesting spin.
What an interesting spin. The center of
those visions was not on Jesus.
It was on the little flock,
those who affirmed the errors of the
Miller chart and the supposed change of
the work in the heavenly sanctuary. It
was a coverup response to refusing to
accept that your movement is built on
falsehoods.
The focus of the first vision is about
the little flock. You said it there. Oh,
it's about them keeping their eyes on
Jesus, right? It's about them supposedly
keeping their eyes on Jesus. Those that
supposedly remained loyal to God by
affirming and yielding to what Dr. Bert
mentioned and that is the midnight cry.
This supposed message which was to
prepare them to enter with Jesus by
faith into the most holy pl or yeah into
the most holy place of the heavenly
sanctuary where he'd begin the
investigative judgment. Those who
rejected this fanaticism and nonsense
supposedly fell off the path because
they took their eyes off Jesus.
just a begging of the question. It's
just a
the massive elephant in the room
is not eyes on Jesus or eyes that it's
that this whole thing is just wrong.
They were wrong.
They were wrong. It's not about Jesus.
It's a cover up to try and cover up a a
major error because you couldn't accept
that you're wrong and that you're not
some special, you know, whatever.
Give it up. Pack up shop. Come join the
Christian church. You don't have to.
It's an ancient faith. We don't need to
think that we're these. It's just crazy,
man. It's crazy. No, the first vision
was about the shut door of mercy and the
early stages of the developing
investigative judgment doctrine. And to
mention that the second vision is all
about Jesus. What a joke.
Dr. Bert, I walked through one and a
half hours worth of source material from
your own employer, the White Estate.
your own sources
where we walked through the issues
regarding the shut door. But even Robert
Olsen,
who held the position you hold now, sir,
though he did present many of the
troubling quotes to his credit, he
didn't dare touch that second vision
manuscript,
where it's shown that Ellen did indeed
say that God showed her that the door of
mercy was shut for everyone who rejected
this message and it was too late. The
opportunity was over.
Why didn't you mention that part, sir?
Or how she mentioned Sister Durban?
That's how she's listed in the
manuscript. Who was heartbroken over
this news and still had a heart for the
lost world, which in the manuscript it
says caused Ellen to be upset because
she thought Sister Durban wasn't
trusting what God had supposedly shown
her.
Ellen was upset that a woman was
burdened for lost souls. though I don't
know what message they were proitizing
but the point being
the vision was all about Jesus.
Just because Jesus is a tertiary
component of the whole does not mean
that it's about him. No, it's about the
little flock. It was always about
themselves coming to Ellen to get
confirmation about themselves because
she's the conduit from God giving his
stamp of approval.
Then he equates rejecting the 1844 and
40 or 43 and 44 blunder with taking your
eyes off Jesus.
The shut door vision is not centered on
Jesus and the cross of Christ.
This is just like the standard lip
service that has to be said to wash over
the facts. It's like they think if they
say it enough it'll just magically
become true. They have to repeat it over
and over and over to themselves to try
and convince themselves of its validity.
Again, simply mentioning Jesus does not
mean something is centered on him. The
focus of Ellen White's early visions was
on the little flock. Jesus was simply a
byproduct.
Even that vision, I can't talk to you
about it right now, but there were a
group of people after the disappointment
in 1844 who thought that Jesus had come
spiritually.
They thought that heaven was spiritual.
They thought that they were in the new
earth already. Hallelujah. you know, the
dead are raised spiritually and all of
this stuff. And I think the reason God
gave her this vision among maybe some
other reasons as well was to make it
clear that no, we have a tangible future
with Jesus.
Okay. So, just something quick here in
passing. When I was in SDA University,
one of my professors, religion
professors,
he said this same sort of thing. This is
that 1800's mentality that they haven't
been able to let go of because their
movement was born in an era and brought
that era with them
to where they think that everyone else
thinks
the second coming has either already
happened or there isn't a physical
return.
That this is something that the SDA
church like really revived and pioneered
that people didn't really believe that.
No, there were groups of people at the
time of the Millerites and the early
adventists
19th century who believed ideas like
this. You had the Jehovah's Witnesses
that were birthed out of all this as
well who believed in a spiritual
resurrection etc. But it's always
positioned as like this is the normative
thing that all those unlearned
Christians understand and believe. We
understand it's a real tangible.
I had to ask this professor after class
or like stop him after class to be like,
"Oh my man, that's dishonest. That's
like not true." Well,
no, it's not true. I'm not an Adventist.
Told him
I believe in the the physical new
heaven, new earth, physical bodily
return of Christ. Christians have
believed this since the apostles.
This had not become lost and need
restored as a concept by Adventists. I
mean, it's stated in the Apostles Creed
for crying out loud,
but the third vision, the the the new
heaven, the new the new earth, it just f
it's just like so baffling. They'll say
these things. I'm like, man, what where
are you getting this information from?
What? What? It's just so flabbergasting.
Every time you hear it, it's just like
you don't talk to Christians much, do
you?
It's just so bizarre. But this idea that
the third vision the of the new earth,
it bolstered this idea of like see the
new heaven and the new earth is going to
actually be physical.
Why? When Christians have believed,
understood this, known this for 2,000
years.
Again, the the underlying assumption is
the church fell away, needed restored,
which is the SDA church, and God was
then correcting error they were
experiencing as a universal correction
of God's true church. This whole system
is circular. It can never be the
elephant in the room that has
elephantitis itself.
Which is that the Adventist church is
just wrong.
It's built on falsities, cover-ups,
lies, and bad theology.
And so she has this virtual experience
because it's a vision. It's not real and
that she's not actually there. But she's
she's taken to the future and she walks
with Jesus in the new earth. He shows
her the living green grass and she sees
the forests that are not dark and I
can't tell you the rest of the vision.
She's so moved. She forgets she's in
vision. And finally she comes to the
table. It's long table. She said, "We
could see clear to the end." And she
goes to sit down and eat. And Jesus
said, "No, you can't eat yet.
You have to go back and tell the people
what you have seen."
And oh, that must have been hard. And
she comes out a vision and her
responses, if you read her description
there after that vision, she says, "It's
dark. So dark." That's what she said.
after seeing the new earth. It's dark,
right? And then she said, "Oh, that I
had wings like a dove that I could fly
away and be at rest. I've seen a better
land." So she comes back as a witness
now
with the testimony of Jesus because he
led her. She says, "He took me. He
showed me it."
And then she said, "I've seen that
better land and we will be there." Don't
talk about this spiritual stuff. Yes,
it's spiritual with Jesus in a sense,
but it's more listen.
It's whole package of salvation. Amen.
It is a precious thing that God has
given us in Jesus.
So, because she said it has to be so,
right? He took me there.
the last human being to interact with
the risen Christ because remember they
don't believe that any souls have gone
to heaven
the souls of those who were martyed that
we read about back in Revelation. No
spirits of the righteous made perfect in
Hebrews 12 in the new heavenly mount
Zion. No no no.
But the last human being to supposedly
interact with the risen Christ is
supposedly Ellen White.
who was given a VIP tour of heaven, the
heavenly sanctuary, the new earth, etc.
Must be true because it sounded so
glorious, right?
He emphasizes this whole thing like, "He
took me there. He did it,
Dr. Bert." All sorts of people make
these same grandiose claims.
There are people who have schemed people
that the kid the some years back the kid
that was in the hospital that claimed to
have to have all those tours to heaven
and his parents made a killing off of
the book.
It's not unique to you guys. Lots of
groups at the same time as yours was
conceived claim this sort of stuff.
And they all claim it's in accordance
with scripture
and they all claim the exact same thing
you do. But then we'll be saying things
that contradict what you guys believe.
But you also see here that Adventists
think that if something isn't spiritual,
it isn't actually real.
This is their physicalist monism shining
through. Notice he's like he's like,
"Well, we do believe it's spiritual, but
Jesus in a in a sense, but don't give me
any of that spiritual stuff.
Scripture says God is spirit." John
4:24. Few weeks ago, we looked on the
the channel at
pretty much the pioneer first work of
Seventh Day Adventism on the topic,
which is The Personality of God by James
White, Ellen's husband.
If you remember what he says, that's
what they're all believing today. It's
what's been handed down to them.
It's like, well, we just reject the
dualism of the radical dualism is the
term they'll use. doesn't deal with the
facts that
when Jesus was walking on the water, the
disciples thought that they saw a ghost.
Spirits do not have flesh and bone as
you see that I have.
But they push this concept of spirit
being physical matter so far to the
point that their false god exists in
time with a phys with a physical body.
It's actually three gods technically. I
know they won't say that, but who all
have tangible corporeal forms. Even the
Holy Spirit, Ellen White toward the end
of her life, we've looked at that on the
channel before, too. That paper from
Jerry Moon where he's documenting this
downforce.
The Holy Spirit has a physical,
tangible, corporeal form, just like the
father does and the son does. And
they're all separate, distinct beings.
Part of the good news of the gospel is
that Christians will be resurrected in
glorified bodies. Again, Apostles Creed,
human bodies, human bodies. We will
forever be human. It's only been fringe
whack job offshoot groups like the hyper
predtoist that say heaven contains no
physicality or hold to some form of
gnostic ideology around physical matter
being bad.
This is again sort of that dig of like
all those unlearned Christians out
there, they have this like spiritual,
you know, this not really real idea. We
believe in real package, full package
salvation,
just word salad, man. This is like
theological word salad.
So Jesus is the center of her prophetic
ministry.
and she saw him, she worshiped him, she
listened to him, she spoke on his
behalf.
This is the earliest picture we have of
Ellen White in 1857.
This is about 13 years after her first
vision.
Spoke on God's behalf.
You understand what's being said there,
folks? You understand how large of a
charge that is? I would never dare make
a claim. I'm speaking on behalf of the
Almighty.
Dr. Bert, thank you for admitting that
she violated the third commandment
regularly.
You've mentioned two of them in this
lecture.
The Miller chart. She said God showed
her it was exactly how he wanted it, but
then it needed changed three times. As
well as the second vision that you
called the bridegroom vision, but it's
actually the shut door vision.
or she did indeed say in the manuscript
the door of mercy was shut for the world
but then pivoted multiple times.
No sir, she did not speak on behalf of
God.
The true God is not a confused deceiver
that holds his hand over the numbers on
a chart to test to see if people will
believe a falsehood to see if they're
really loyal.
It's abominable.
It's heretical. It's blasphemous.
It's a serious penalty. And if Ellen
lived in a previous time to when she did
live,
she'd been stoned.
That's how serious it was in God's
economy.
I want to skip ahead here because he
basically just shows pictures and how
they've been colorized. some um
here we go. I want to take a few minutes
here before we we're going to look at
two parts. As I said, we want to talk
about Ellen White in scripture. We're
going to talk about Ellen White and 7th
Adventist doctrine. These are the two
things we want to spend a little more
time on. Ellen White's very clear on the
Bible being the foundation of our faith.
Um there are these are just three of
dozens of places and ways that Ellen
White actually is very clear on the
Bible being
our rule of faith and this idea the
Protestant view understanding of solar
scriptor the Bible she wrote and the
Bible alone is our rule of faith. the
Bible and the Bible alone is to be our
creed, the sole bond of union. And she
understood herself,
yes, to have received prophetic
revelation, although she didn't call
herself a prophet. I know in this group
you'll know what she called herself,
some of you will know. How did she refer
to herself,
the Lord's messenger?
And she writes in a couple of places.
It's not that she's rejecting the the
the reality that she has received
prophetic revelation, but she did not
want people to think that she was
somehow trying to put herself forward as
as additional scripture. And more than
that, she said her work was more than
just a prophet. And she explains what
that means, which we don't have time to
talk about right now, but it's it would
be rich if we could spend some time on
it. You can go back to selected messages
uh book one and you can read about that
some uh the scope of her ministry of
what God called her to do went beyond
that of the prophetic gift. But she saw
herself as a postbiblical
non-cononical prophet. And what do we
mean by that? Well, it's post-biblical
that means the end of time.
Non-cononical then would mean that she
is not a part of the scripture. Isn't
that right? The canon of scripture. She
did not see herself as additional
scripture. So let's read what she says.
This is the introduction to great
controversy that she wrote.
Okay, so this will be the last section
we get at tonight. I see that we're at
about the 2hour mark. We'll end up
picking up on the same section again um
in part two and we'll get to the
non-cononical versus canonical next
goound. But we heard it again. I'm going
to point this out every time. And
actually, before I get into that, I'm
going to point out something else as
well. For all the Adventists that want
to b and scoff and say, "You don't even
understand how to correctly read Ellen
White's writings. You're quoting from
all these other obscure sources over
here. You don't even understand the
proper hierarchy. I haven't consulted
with the Adventist magisterium, if you
will." But it's funny, folks.
Bert has c has quoted from Ted Wilson
will quote from Steven Bore will quote
from Doug Wilson or Doug Wilson Doug
Bachelor will quote from all these same
works that I quote from and yet they'll
b scoff sometimes at selected messages.
That's not part of the conflict of the
ages series.
Okay, let's stick with patriarchs and
prophets great controversy and desire of
ages. Not going to help.
But here it is every time they quote
from it. Oh, it's just plainly
understood. It's just easy to
understand, easy to know. Yeah, he's
quoting from early writing, selected
messages. Oh, but when Miles does that.
Oh, no, no, no, now it's obscure. Now
it's hard to understand.
You're not using the right hierarchy.
You don't understand. Those aren't
authoritative. They're Give me a break.
Give me a break. It's not going to work,
Adventist. That's not going to work. She
said it was all or nothing.
Never wrote a single sentence of heresy.
words in her books barricaded by thus
sayith the Lord. This downplaying that
he's doing here is the the parcel split
tongue of Ellen White.
Oh, she always exalted the Bible. Oh,
except for those times where she said if
you go against her writings, you're
going to have the spirit of God
withdrawn from you. What a blasphemous
statement.
But the last thing I want to get at
here, we've addressed this before,
folks.
They are not soul of scripture
wrongfully defined it again. They always
wrongfully define it. This is them term
borrowing
to try and appear like they are attached
to something else.
No creed but the Bible. That's not solos
scripture.
That's antithetical to solo scripture.
The Bible and the Bible alone is our
only rule of faith. That's not solos
scriptor.
Some of you might be asking, it's not.
No, it's not. And this is precisely the
problem.
This is why we need to be very specific.
And when there's terms that refer to
something specific, you can't just
switch up the definition by removing
words, whether it's all of the words,
and completely porting in a different
definition or removing key phrases or
keywords from the definition, which
fundamentally alter the definition, but
then call it the same thing.
Soloscriptura, we're going to bring up
Charles Hodgeg's systematic theology
here. I think he's qualified to um just
lay out the basic framework here. Very
first sentence, all Protestants agree in
teaching that the word of God as
contained in the scriptures of the Old
and New Testaments is the only
infallible
rule of faith and practice.
It's not the belief that the scriptures
are the sole theological source for all
of your beliefs.
Creeds, councils, confessions have a
level of authority.
They're just not infallible.
Basically, they can be reformed. That's
the belief. That's that's what being
reformed is.
It's not a comp it's not like
restoration like the Adventist church
believes and teaches. that the church
needed restored because it fell away.
And we're here as a last day church that
God raised up at the right time to
essentially restore the church. And then
they'll try and latch on to the
coattails of the reformers to be like,
"Well, we're just like the reformers
were." No, reformation and restoration
are not the same thing.
But again, that is not the definition of
solos scriptor. What the Adventist
church affirms or what they claim to
affirm, but they don't even really hold
to this either because Ellen White is a
level of authority. They can dance
around and do the musical chairs on this
all they want, but the facts are the
facts.
She is a level of authority. He was just
talking about earlier how Jesus is
speaking through her. And when we submit
to when Jesus is speaking, it shines the
light in in the darkness of our hearts
and exalts Jesus. And so that's why we
can't reject this, right?
But then now it's, oh, we're going to
downplay. It's not equal with scripture.
Even though it is the Holy Spirit, it
it's just a big cluster and a mess,
folks. It's a big cluster and a mess.
the Adventist church. What they put
forth there in that definition is what
is called biblicism or nuda scriptur
pulled from the word denuted meaning
completely removing the Bible from
history and those that came before us
and then the whole Bible and me under a
tree. We just sat down in a group and
then this woman starts getting visions
supposedly that's giving the stamp of
approval from God that this is what
we're supposed to be doing because God
was totally behind 1843 and 44.
So we just believe the Bible. It's
biblicism. That's not solos scriptura.
The same people that you're using the
word solos scripura, the reformers,
they did not believe like you guys do.
Why are you using a term from our
tradition
and then trying to tell us how it's
properly defined?
No. Get out of dodge. You don't know
what you're talking about. You guys are
like the Sinians.
Bible only isism.
But really, it isn't Bible only because
Ellen White gives these supposed
inspired details to what's already found
in the text. And that's what he's going
to end up getting into into the next
part. Like I said, we're going to end it
on this part, but I I really wish the
Adventist church would stop with the
term borrowing to try and blend in, but
really they twist and redefined every
phrase and term that they borrow from
Christians to mean something different.
Muddying the waters, confusing people.
Trinity,
solos scriptorera, justification by
faith, righteousness by faith.
Own it, Adventists. Own it. Own it that
you are your own thing.
Stop trying to ride the coattails of
Christians, but then at the same time be
saying, "Well, they're the apostate
Protestants and we're God's last day
remnant and well, we don't believe we're
the only ones saved." It's always both
sides of the fence back and forth trying
to play both sides of the field because
you don't understand that Ellen White
was not an integrative thinker and was
trying to hold this thing together with
duct tape over all of the years that she
was alive trying to essentially build
this thing and turn it into a cash cow
and all these other things. Hopefully
Steve Daly is going to come on to the
show at some point in the coming months
and we're going to talk about his book
and specifically that stuff. But
folks, they're they're confused on a
number of things. Um, they're stuck in
the 1800s.
They redefine and just twist
terminology that has historic
definitions.
They'll tell you out of one side of
their mouth, we're we're firmly in the
Wesley and Armenian lane, but then
they'll also tell you in the next
breath, we're heirs of the Reformation.
It just, you know, they'll tell you with
Michael the Archangel, we believe like
the reformers do, the law of God. We
believe like the reformers do. No, you
don't. No, you don't. Just because they
believe these Michael the Archangel does
not mean they believe the same thing you
do. Just because they didn't believe
that the law was nailed to the cross
like the Antonyomians say, doesn't mean
that they agree with your use and
unlawful use of the law.
It's just silly to make these appeals.
It's them trying to attach their
movement to legitimate movements from
the past to ride under the radar as
though they're just like the rest of us,
but really they're sent in the world on
a special mission from God supposedly to
bring this special, you know, the
fullness of the gospel as we've looked
about as we looked at in that Herbert
Douglas paper in the cursed gospel of
Adventism part one. They're restoring
the fullness of the gospel to all the
other people who have limited gospels.
and that if you don't come out of this,
you're going to experience the wrath of
God. The plagues are going to be poured
on you. You're going to get the mark of
the beast. You're a pagan. You're worse
than the heathen.
You're in rebellion. Your prayers are an
abomination to God. These sorts of
quotes that they don't want to latch on
to, that they want to downplay. You're
reading this wrong. You don't know what
you're talking about. You're confused.
I've heard it all, folks. And I'm
telling you, if you're going to engage
with Seventh Day Adventist, you just got
to parse through this stuff, understand
where the issues are, and it nine times
out of ten is going to come down to
definitions and or the context of
scripture. As we saw tonight, he tried
to use second Peter. Second Peter was
not at all about bolstering the
spiritual gift of prophecy.
He tried using or or appealing to and he
presented their standard Revelation
12:17, 19:10.
We went through all the use cases. I
believe all the use cases in Revelation.
We looked at John's epistle, his or his
first epistle. We looked at his gospel,
the consistent usage of this. We looked
at his claim to the taramme that the
tarammes support this idea of Revelation
12:17 talking about Ellen White because
it's talking about the spirit of God
being manifested on somebody when no,
the tarams actually
support our what Christians would
interpret this to mean, which is that
it's the spirit of God himself, the
testimony of Jesus being the gospel,
which Jesus is bearing testimony in. And
yeah, it is found in the scriptures when
when prophets of old did speak on behalf
of God legitimately. Yes, that was an
act of the Holy Spirit upon the
individual, but it's not exclusively to
that act, folks. All believers have the
spirit of prophecy dwelling within them.
We are the body of Christ.
And the spirit bears testimony of Jesus.
He even testifies of Jesus.
It's all about the gospel. the gospel
adventist,
not health message, not seventh day
Sabbath, not end times remnant marked by
the gift of prophecy through Ellen White
and knowing every sign, symbol, seal
claiming the beast is this and this and
that. You know, every date and every
number, but man, you can't even
articulate who God is. You can't even
just articulate the gospel simply. I'm
having a discussion with an Adventist
this past week. I'm like, man, what
would you tell somebody if you had to
just tell them you knew they were about
to die and it's your last call?
You got,
you know, 15, maybe 15 minutes. This guy
was saying he was going to struggle to
even be able to get in what he needed
to. Man, if it takes you 15 minutes to
explain to somebody what they need to
know to be made right with God, I'm
sorry, folks. You don't have the gospel.
It is not that crazy and convoluted. The
gospel is not every theological belief
that you hold to. It's not, "Oh man, I
got to give this guy a systematic
theology presentation in 15 minutes of
every single belief." No, the gospel is
a distinct message.
a distinct message that was handed down
by the Lord Jesus Christ himself to the
apostles
who then handed it down to the saints
and have been teaching it on this earth
from that time to the present day.
It's always been here. The church will
never be overcome.
It can be it needs to be reformed in
certain areas. That's the argument the
reformers are making with the western
Latin branch of the church. But not that
the church has gone completely apostate
and needs restored. That's not the same
thing.
It's simply basically that we're talking
about solos scripura. Solura is a claim
about where infallibility lies. It's
really a claim about what the ultimate
infallible authority is and that there's
only one of those versus two infallible
sources of authority.
It isn't that creeds confessions
don't have any level of authority. Yes,
they do. God has been leading his
church. It's simply that the church can
make errors and has and needs to reform
in certain areas and we need to reform
in light of the scriptures.
So, I hope tonight's stream here was
beneficial for you. Like I said, it was
a little rocky in some places because I
have a new setup going on here um that I
think I'm actually going to keep moving
forward for the rest of the streams um
because I'll get better used to it and
I'll be a little bit more smooth. Um,
but hopefully this was beneficial for
you guys. Hopefully you got to hear and
see if you've never been an Adventist
some of these common claims, assertions,
um, some of these foundational texts
that they use. And yet again, context is
king. Um, it's going to win nine times
out of 10 as we saw. So, we will pick
this up again in the next part. I don't
know when exactly that will be. Speaking
of next things, really quick, some
housekeeping things before we sign off
here. uh Monday
live stream this channel. Dr. Brandt
Bosserman,
we're going to be talking about the
Sabbath.
You're going to want to be here. We're
going to be talking first versus
seventh. Dr. Bossman, great guy. He is a
theological beast on the Trinity, but
also is a um beast on sabotarianism
specifically.
So, Monday 7 p.m. this channel, Dr.
Brandt Bosserman will be here. The
following week, uh, that Monday, so a
week from next Monday or this coming
Monday,
Pastor Aaron Lyles is going to be back,
former Adventist, now Baptist pastor,
and we're going to be talking about the
state of the dead and the nature of man.
Don't miss that one.
We're going to talk about some aspects
of um
this single coin. It's really two sides
of the same coin. And I don't think
there's a lot of discussion or enough
discussion out there about the um
Adventist physicalism and the impact
that that has on the nature of man and
how that un um informs their
understanding of what it means to be
born again. Um
the the war between the flesh and the
spirit. Um a whole host of things. So,
we're going to be getting into some good
stuff during that stream. So, that's
kind of the the direction things are
going in. The last thing I'll say is
this, folks. We need your help.
July 1st, a big announcement is coming.
It's going to involve you guys.
We need your help.
This thing is sort of taking a mind of
its own and is developing into more of a
full-on enterprise. The YouTube channel
has gotten legs, so to speak. We were a
little tadpole in the pond. Still are,
but it Well, maybe we're like a a little
toad now in the big pond. But I say that
to say
things are ramping up. We're going to be
doing more stuff. We're filming some
boots on the ground content tomorrow, me
and a couple former Adventist friends.
Great content. Hopefully,
we're going to be engaging with Seventh
Day Adventists out on the street.
But what's coming is more than just the
YouTube channel. So, I'm not going to
spill the beans on what all of that
stuff is going to be, but it's going to
involve needing your guys's help.
It's going to make a big impact.
At a certain point, the Adventist church
is going to have to respond.
If you think we're misrepresenting, if
you're an Adventist, you think I have no
clue what I'm talking about, tell me
where I've misrepresented. Come on to
answering Adventism. Let's see it. Let's
see who's done their homework. That goes
for any Adventist scholar, pastor,
professor.
Let's do it.
Guys are going to have to respond at
some point.
I'm not doing this just because I have
an axe to grind. We're serious about
this. The scriptures call us to silence
the arguments
of vanity, falsity.
The truth is the anvil that can wear out
any hammer.
We're going to make a big impact, folks.
God is just getting started. The prayer
has always been, God, use this to draw a
people to yourself.
me a a bumpkin in Nashville, Tennessee,
no theology degree, no theology
background,
a number of years of street evangelism,
just passionate about apologetics,
theology in general. God, use it for
your glory. God's using it for his
glory. He's going to keep saving people.
But more on that front in the weeks to
come. Just kind of wanted to wet the
appetite on that. So, with that said,
I'm going to end it like I always do. um
Adventists,
your call to us is to come out of her,
my people. And so my response to you is
um likewise. Come out of her, my people.
We're here for you when you're ready to
join us. Till next time, God bless.
[Music]